[Music]
we all binge watch stranger things on
Netflix in 2016 and now we keep watching
the trailers over and over again to know
what's coming next
we know that 11:00 is coming back and
that will is seeing things but we found
out many other clues that could tell us
what is going to happen in the second
season make sure you watch this video
until the end to know what its gonna
happen to one of our favorite characters
barb if you love stranger things as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you 10 hidden
messages in the stranger things season 2
trailers you might have missed the year
as soon as we saw the first trailer
during the Superbowl we had the
opportunity to understand that the
second season was set in 1984 one year
after the first season you could see it
in the video of will getting examined
the time stamp read October 30th 1984 it
was later confirmed when we watched the
other trailers one of them was even
called 1984 and showed pictures of what
happened that year the other trailers
clearly showed that it was Halloween we
loved to see our favorite characters
wearing the Ghostbusters costume and it
could even become a big part of the
story stay tuned to see how hey guys we
are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup acts and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section hear from
you there the eggo commercial when you
watch the first trailer during the
Superbowl you probably thought that they
used an eggo commercial simply because
11 loves those waffles but if you watch
the whole commercial you probably notice
something that could tell us what's
going to happen in the TV series the two
kids were fighting over who was going to
have the egg oh the girl talked about
the taste of those delicious waffles but
the boy tried something else he told his
sister that a green and purple creature
with a million legs was crawling up her
arm could that be the monster maybe
that's a coincidence but we don't think
it could be if the producers paid so
much money for a commercial during the
Super Bowl they've probably thought
about this the monster the more we
watched the new trailers the more we
could understand what the monster was
going to look like but some people think
that we actually knew this since the end
of the first season the boys were
battling what they called a tehsil Hydra
in Dunn
and Dragons when we watched the trailers
and saw the monster on a piece of paper
and in the sky we thought that it looked
really similar could the monster
actually be a tehsil Hydra we'll have to
watch the second season of stranger
things to find out and we think the
games can give us a lot of clues as you
will see if you keep watching this video
the movie references if you watch the
trailers you obviously notice the
reference to the Ghostbusters movie that
hit theaters in 1984 the year when the
TV series is set this movie is so
important that the boys are even wearing
costumes inspired by the movie and try
to catch the monster in a box but that's
not the only movie reference we could
see in the trailer as the other is less
known there is a reference to the 1977
movie Close Encounters of the Third Kind
when a boy is standing in front of a
door and something terrible is happening
outside and we're pretty sure that these
are not the only references that we're
going to see in the TV series the video
games since the first trailer for the
Super Bowl we saw a spinning arcade sign
then we got the chance to see what
happened in that scene in the comic-con
trailer the last time we saw will he was
holding a wrapped Atari a video game
console this is why we think that the
boys will stop playing Dungeons &
Dragons and will turn to something more
modern instead and it also means that we
will see a lot of video games from the
80s in the second season the most
important one will probably be dragon's
lair as seen in the comic-con trailer
and you'll have to stay tuned to see why
the dragon's lair in the first season of
stranger things the boys were playing
Dungeons & Dragons it was more important
than we thought as the plot was similar
to what happened in the game in the game
we'll had the chance to attack the
monster or hide and he did the same
thing in the game and in real life some
fans think that the second season will
be similar to the game they play in the
comic-con trailer dragon's lair
unfortunately the boys quickly lost at
that game when they were attacked by the
monster if this theory is true it could
mean that we're going to see a really
bad ending in the second season the
upside-down when we watched the first
trailer all we could think about was if
11 was coming back this is why we were
really happy to see her open her eyes in
the trailer but the creator's did
something really interesting to show us
where she was they put her upside down
meaning that she was in the upside down
world this theory was later confirmed
when we watch the other trailers and
we're even happier to see that she will
be coming back in the real world
- but what will happen to her after
spending so much time in this terrifying
world only the future will tell us the
new character if you played and beat
stranger things the game you had the
chance to see a new scene from stranger
things season 2 only a few people saw
this it's just a normal Halloween night
of trick-or-treating and the boys are
wearing their Ghostbusters costume but
they are tired of people thinking that
they are the three musketeers this is
when someone pops out of nowhere and
scares them when they take off their
masks the boys see that it was actually
a girl that's a new character that we
can't wait to meet in the second season
the best friend when we watched the
trailers we were disappointed to see
that barb was nowhere to be seen
she disappeared while her friend was
making out with her new boyfriend and
everyone thought that she was the last
character who deserved to go in the
upside-down world this is why people
asked for justice for barb you might
think that this character might come
back as a surprise in the second season
but the actress actually confirmed at
the Comic Con that she wouldn't be
coming back for a second season but that
doesn't mean that her best friend won't
try to do her best to finally know what
happened to her it's never too late for
justice the incubator after watching the
trailers fans had a really interesting
theory they think that will could now be
an incubator for the monster of the
upside-down world this is how they're
going to enter the real world this is
why a slug came out of his mouth and why
he was not even shocked by it and why he
keeps seeing things he knows so much
about the monsters that he can draw a
map to tell people where it is we can't
wait to see if this theory makes sense
did you see anything else in the
trailers for the second season of
stranger things don't be shy to tell us
what it is in the comment section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 hidden messages in the
stranger things season 2 trailer you
might have missed for more spooky
stories like this make sure you watch 10
epic kids costume ideas for Halloween
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]